the angel on the bridge pub in henley
has had a policy of six to a table
since lockdown now their rule is the
country's rule
groups above six are illegal anywhere
and the landlord here is delighted it
sits at a table seated
no standing around and they would always
do that and then five minutes later
there would be 12 round the table
uh it's just like herding cats really
but i think it's about
who you let in in the first place and
we're doing over 21 rule at the moment
we might go up to over 25s it really is
the young ones who
they've no real care about social
distancing or
you know taking taking covert home
certainly his younger patrons expressed
a sense of virus
regulation fatigue i don't think it
really matters
i don't doesn't really like seem like
it's being applied and
people do it anyway so do you think you
think people will
ignore the rules yeah i think what will
happen is
once it flares up again our age group
and our demographic will get blamed
in this edinburgh park people playing
sport are allowed to exceed six
but this gathering of 12 sitting down if
they're not in a bubble
is breaking the rules here on brighton
beach everyone seems to be bunched
in legal numbered groups so how easy is
all this to police
well the rule of six is at least some
clarity clarity that the public needs so
they know what the rules are
but also for the police to enforce them
it is going to be difficult
because we don't have the resource to do
real detail work
and there are frustrations for business
back in henley this boat company
can sell numerous tickets for a socially
distanced river cruise
but 60 of trade is chartering and a
group of any more than six
friends for example wouldn't be allowed
to book this boat
unless it was a wedding and then it's
only up to 30 people
we've had to take a big backward step
again end of august we had a
exemption from the 30 rule which meant
that we could um
after a risk assessment on each party go
above the 30 threshold
take 50 or 60. and now we're back down
to the six which is going to have to
cause us all the
administrative hassle and also the lack
of business
i'm of the mind of you know i really
don't want to have a second lockdown
let's let's
you know put the rules in place to
really stamp this stamp this out so we
can get back to some sort of normality
and that's the bigger question not
whether the rule of six can be enforced
but whether it will be enough jason
farrell
sky news